[Music]
foreign
here in this video we will reveal the
new Titan that is confirmed to appear in
Godzilla XCOM gxk the new Empire this
new enemy Titan isn't one of the old
ones that was seen in the previous
movies neither was it seen in the comics
or any other material this is a brand
new villain that will complement Scar
the red Kong as an evil Ally just as
Godzilla and Kong will team up to fight
in this epic showdown kind of like a
Godzilla vs Kong whole thing Square
Battle Royale so let's get to it so
let's start with how the information was
acquired well as Godzilla fans we scour
the internet for any kind of news and
information about Big G and Kong
especially with the recent teaser of gxk
there was a test screening and certain
people were invited not us we are from a
poor remote part of the planet like
Skull Island we can only analyze the
primary data and bring forth useful
secondary information there was a reveal
by most of us journalists the likes of
viewer Annan Miss H and KDM of which
they confirmed that some rumors and
theories are true but some are not the
test creating was one of the first ones
and therefore the end product the final
movie could still be way different
but yeah the one thing that is finalized
is the appearance and the plotline about
a new Titan maybe the original Titan of
the master verse this creature rumored
and well confirmed by the ones who got
access to the screening is really a new
talent that was actually revealed in a
cave hieroglyph in Call of Duty GVK the
old one DLC that was seen a couple of
years back and it won't be a legacy
Kaiju like space Godzilla Destroyer or
Anguirus the name is shimu the world
ending Thailand that will shock quite a
few moviegoers he will be the second big
enemy monster to appear in the movie
shimu actually appeared in one of the
cave drawings in Call of Duty versus go
on crossover DLC kind of like a monster
Easter egg that only a few notice and
even fewer considered it worthwhile
so going by what we heard the shimu
Titans design would have a pale or a
white body he would be bipedal maybe
quarter pedal at times and there would
be a massive mass of Crystal spikes on
his back which made us think about space
Godzilla initially but since the ones
that have seen him in the screening were
sure that he wasn't a space Godzilla but
he was an original design we would not
doubt that just saying that you know
space Goji also had crystals anyway if
the Cod heroglyph is now considered
Canon then based on the cave painting he
would also have horns on his head a
larger head compared to Godzilla and
would have deadly and massive teeth he
would also have a long tail with spiky
or Bob endings no doubt his size would
be bigger since he would be the big bad
So based on what we have heard this
title would also be very old and maybe
one of the original Super species on the
planet maybe he even came from space and
then mutated the other creatures into
Titans but the spacebot is just
speculation shimu would be a talent that
have been dominant for millions of years
and therefore forgotten and even unknown
to the present-day monsters as the
synopsis read a colossal undiscovered
threat this means that shimu would
definitely be bigger than a big G and
Kong and even bigger than Scar the red
Kong and as for shimu's Powers he was
revealed to have ice powers therefore
causing ice ages at different times of
the planet his main weapon would be a
freeze breath which turns everything to
ice quite the opposite of Godzilla and
his super hot Atomic breath their battle
shall be A Song of Ice and Fire
so the four patterns officially confirm
our Godzilla gong shimu and Scar there's
a theory that shimu is mind controlled
by Scar or at the very least a pawn of
the red calm keep in mind that scar was
said to be a Titan Hunter and the one
that caused the ancient Titan war in the
hollow Earth further revealed say that
he alongside other ape Titans wanted to
rule the world but was eventually
defeated by Godzilla himself which may
be the reason why Godzilla hated and
hunted com in GVK anyway the movie will
have two major protagonists and two
major antagonists there will also be
other talents in it especially the ones
from kotm that were missing in GVK gxk
will redeem that and have a buttload of
Apes reptiles and Kaiju in the mix
so in a nutshell the main threats would
be a hunter killer Thailand that hates
Godzilla and also one that betrayed the
ancient Kong species therefore he would
have motive to kill them both and then
there is shimu who would cause the
entire planet to freeze therefore being
a malevolent force of nature also an
ultimate rival to the G-Man
so I hope you have enjoyed watching this
video do hit the like button for support
and subscribe but most of all smash that
Bell icon for regular updates on new
videos right here on this channel take
care monster fans